Joining me today as a contributor for
Canada's national post known here on the
Youtube,
as my name is Josephine,
Josephine.
Matthias,
welcome to the Rubin Room.
Thank you for having me.
I'm so excited to be here.
So your real name is Josefina.
My name is Jason.
I know a lot of people don't believe
that.
I think it's like an alias isn't really
not that believable.
You say,
my name is Josephine and people are
always getting pumped on line.
So they were curious.
Sorry,
that was gonna say.
I think they assume it's like bunky show
or something to Joseph until really
late.
All.
Alright,
well I'm,
I'm really super psyched that you're
here.
We met about a month and a half ago in
Toronto after Jordan Peterson thing.
We got to chat a little bit and I've
been a fan of what you're doing for
awhile and I think you're actually one
of the few people on the youtube making
some sense.
Whoa.
I feel fresh.
Okay.
So,
uh,
let's just do a little bit about your
history first and then we're gonna play
a clip from one of your videos in case
people haven't seen some of your stuff
and then we're going to talk about all
sorts of political stuff because you are
a true political beast.
So you're originally from Nigeria.
I lived there for what,
eight or nine years before he moved to
Canada.
So tell me about growing up in Nigeria.
Yeah.
Um,
I actually don't remember much about
growing up in Nigeria and my parents
kind of a closed me off to what was
really going on.
I lived in a gated community and um,
yeah,
I immigrated here when I was nine years
old.
My Dad actually first went to Canada
when I was two.
Uh,
he got here on a work visa,
worked his ass off for years,
for about seven years actually.
I didn't even know who my dad was for
seven years.
And then when he got his visa and
everything,
he brought my family over and yeah,
now I'm in.
I'm in Canada.
I mean a great country.
Yeah.
So what did your dad do?
Was able to get a visa to go there.
Yeah.
My Dad was an accountant and then when
he got to Canada he went back to school
and decided to do nursing inside.
And my mom's a teacher,
so that's,
that's what they do.
What does your mom teach?
Uh,
she teaches.
She taught English in Nigeria and now
she kind of teaches special ed kids and
stuff like that.
So she still loves teaching.
She obviously can't teach a Nigerian
person can teach English in Canada,
but yeah.
So she still loves teaching,
so I'm glad she's still kind of gets to
do that.
But yeah.
So my dad's accountant,
my dad,
my mom's a teacher.
Yeah.
Do your parents tell you anything about
the political situation or anything at
the time when you were growing up?
Even if you don't have great memories of
it?
Uh,
not necessarily.
My parents were not really that
political.
I think we became more political when we
came to Canada and I mean politics in
Nigeria is just,
it's completely corrupt.
There's no such thing as politics.
It's all just money.
And um,
it was when I came to Canada is when
they start to get a little bit more
political and uh,
I don't know,
I think religion and strict parents
kinda create conservatism in a way.
So they're very,
very conservative.
Uh,
so I grew up about,
um,
around that,
but they didn't really name it as
conservatism.
It was just strict and religious and had
all these rules that basically apply to
conservatism in the way.
Yeah.
So then you get to Canada,
you're not even 10 years old.
What was that like to be in a new
country?
So weird here.
I think it was 16 degrees outside and I
was freezing.
So why is it so cold?
And it was people wearing tee shirts.
I did not understand.
Uh,
I remember like driving from the
airport,
I think it's piercing airport and we all
stopped and was like,
why are we stopping?
And they're like,
oh,
it's a red light.
Like what does that mean?
Don't you just go with us?
Everyone has figured out.
My Dad's like,
there's order here.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
And snow.
Snow is the best one.
I think I spent like half an hour just
like touching it and like,
what is this?
And my elementary school teachers or
middle school teachers had to tell me to
get back inside.
But yeah,
it was,
it was really,
it was surreal.
It was a culture shock.
So it was mostly a weather related,
whether an order,
whether an order.
Exactly.
It's basically it,
whether in order.
So when you say you grew up in like a in
a religious atmosphere,
what was that like?
My parents were just super religious and
they hoped I'd be also as religious as
them.
Unfortunately I'm not.
But I think that kinda comes with age
and also living in a different country.
Nigeria,
it's easier,
easier.
The majority of people are religious.
Um,
but yeah,
they,
they are still a very,
very good Catholic Protestants.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So,
okay.
So now you're in Canada,
you're a kid,
you're making a good life for yourself.
When did you get interested in politics?
Oh,
I got interested in politics a while I'm
taking political science and studying
political science in school right now.
And um,
I was also president of the debate club,
I was just interested in like this
scores and discussing things.
I was interested in people's ideas and
different ideas and reasoning,
the reason for things.
Um,
but I also think my political views were
really shaped by me immigrating to
Canada and we lived in the inner cities.
I'm not sure if you've ever heard of
Jane and finch by any chance.
It's Kinda like a south side of Chicago
lights,
like it's not,
it's obviously not as bad,
but it's an inner city majority black,
um,
you know,
poor neighborhoods.
I lived there for most of my Canadian
life actually.
And then from there I moved to a more
higher income neighborhood and having to
experience that.
So it was really cool kind of seeing
like the culture there and then get
another culture shock and move somewhere
else.
So it's like I've experienced,
you know,
Nigeria in the inner city in Canada and
then a much more well off neighborhood.
So,
which would you say is the best out of
those three?
Nigeria know all of neighborhood.
But yeah,
living in the inner cities really shaped
my views because now when I look back I
was like,
oh,
that makes sense.
You are a product of your environment.
And a lot of people that,
you know,
I think about two slash three of my
friends made it out of there.
The majority of them are pregnant or
single parents now they're in the system
and it's unfortunate and weird to see
that happen.
And my parents being extremely strict
and they gave me a curfew at like 5:00
PM everyday.
I wasn't allowed to have boyfriends,
which I guess I was young,
I probably shouldn't have,
but they were really,
really strict and I hated them at that
time.
I didn't understand why they didn't me
to go out and play
with people and now I get it because I
would have ended up like a lot of the
people that are still there right now.
And then yeah,
moving to the much better neighborhood.
I realized that while there is a
difference,
there is a cultural difference I guess.
But so when I've watched a ton of your
videos,
I thought,
all right,
I sensed that she basically is a liberal
kind of liberal,
but I think you have probably some
conservative leanings perhaps,
or at least have an understanding.
I think that's what you're laying out
here.
You have an understanding of that line
of thinking.
Yeah.
You consider yourself a classical
liberal.
I don't want to push you,
but I'd like to hear you say it but,
but what do you actually consider your
views to be okay here?
I know everyone says they don't like
putting labels,
but I absolutely hate labels because
like I have some conservative ideas.
I have some liberal ideas,
I have some classical liberal ideas.
Um,
I have some progressive ideas,
socialist ideas.
Um,
but I guess I just see a look of things
from issue to issue,
but I,
um,
you know,
primarily liberal,
but I'm fiscally conservative.
So that's kind of where I lean I guess.
So the route I think of,
of your ideas,
he's sort of individualization.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
You want to throw to a clip?
Yes,
let's do it.
Alright.
Let's get people to know you in your
natural environment.
West has also been tweeting about the
lack of freedom of thought in America
and the backlash about whether blacks
can be allowed to be Republicans.
Sure is helping prove his point,
but black Americans,
contrary to popular belief,
can hold wildly diverse and opposing
opinions and political issues.
Maybe Connie was a republican.
I mean he's ever referred to himself as
such,
of course,
but he said something about trump that
wasn't severely negative,
so he suddenly the Black Paul Ryan,
but even if he is so what?
In fact,
a 2012 study by Vincent Hutchins and
King Jefferson using data from the
American national election studies found
that 45 percent of black Americans
identify as conservatives.
Despite this,
however,
the Democratic Party typically receives
85 to 95 percent of the black American
vote.
The tendency of black Americans to vote
Democrat allows the to believe that they
have a strong hold on the black American
vote.
In fact,
back in 2016 when Connie was announced
he would run for president in 20,
20,
the Democratic Party's official twitter
account immediately assumed.
He meant you'd be running for them
responding.
Welcome to the race,
Mr West.
Glad to have you.
If only the Dems had Ron Kanye in 2016,
better candidate than she who shall not
be named.
All right.
So I,
I picked that one because I think this
is a great example of what you do.
There's,
there's information and facts and it's
kind of light to and fun and all that
good stuff.
Now,
first off though,
as a black Canadian yapping about black
Americans,
that's kind of racist,
wouldn't you say?
Yeah.
I think I've gotten a lot of comments
when people say like he don't understand
what it's like to be black in America
and it's like,
oh my gosh,
I thought I can have those same
discussions about race relations in
America.
It's just a little scaled down in,
in the Canadian context.
And I think a lot of Canadians try to
project,
I guess I American issues on Canadians
as well.
So,
um,
but yeah,
no,
I,
I do get that criticism,
which is annoying.
We should all be allowed to talk about
whatever we want.
You are a black in America right now?
Yes,
I am.
I know it's awful.
I mean by 10 times people are yelling
the n word at me.
I mean I just,
I feel so unsafe.
Well that's why we create a safe space
for you.
Thank you.
Okay.
So I won't hook that video though
because the numbers that you laid out
there are actually kind of incredible
and something that we obviously have
been talking about lately related to
Kanye and candice and the rest of it for
45 percent of black Americans consider
themselves conservative yet at 85 to 95
percent are voting democrat.
That is a massive disconnect.
So.
So what do you make of that?
Yeah,
I think there's an idea that the
Democratic Party is the best one for
black Americans.
It's the one that's going to help black
Americans.
And although they are conservative in
the true sense of the word,
they aren't necessarily Republican.
They don't believe in the Republican
Party.
Um,
but it is,
it is very interesting,
I mean no one group or identity bolts
the same way as black Americans do.
So there is some kind of,
I guess,
story that's being told to them that
this is the way to do it.
This is the way to go.
And I don't think,
you know,
the Republican party per se is the way
to go and I don't think the Democratic
Party,
in fact,
I think both parties are just garbage at
this point.
Um,
but yeah,
I think it's a little odd that the
majority,
95 percent vote one single way,
but yet there are still conservative in
a sense.
Um,
but yeah,
I just think it's,
it's a,
it's a leftover ideas,
like they just need to kind of start to
refigure things out.
But first we probably have to start
with,
you know,
changing up the government and changing
up the party systems and try to find who
to vote for instead of just picking
Democrat or a Republican.
Do you think this was more of a good
sell job by the Democrats are a bad cell
job by the Republicans because when you
look at all this,
the cities,
especially where it's the worst for
black people,
they're always democrat run cities for
decade after decade after decade.
Yet black people still extremely high
numbers keep voting Democrat.
So that's obviously a great sell job if
somebody's doing some serious pr
workload.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
And um,
I think it's also the Republicans as
well.
I think Black Democrats make it feel
like the Republicans are against the
black Americans and the Democrats and
the Republicans make it feel like,
you know,
the black Americans are against the
Republicans.
Like it's just,
I think both sides are not necessarily
trying to help.
They're just trying to pander to their
own side.
But it is interesting that you've been
voting Democrat for so long and things
are not getting better.
It's like,
oh,
maybe I should start voting a different
way,
or maybe I should start criticizing the
Democratic Party.
I think that's actually the biggest
thing is it's not picking a side.
It's criticizing what they're doing
wrong.
It's criticizing,
you know,
this didn't work.
Let's try something else.
Instead of just saying we need Democrat.
That's it.
This is what's gonna happen,
but it's clearly not not working.
Let's try to figure out what policy
changes we need instead of trying to
pick like,
you know,
Democrat or Republican.
Sorry,
I keep saying that.
I've never gotten.
No,
I'm with you.
So I know you're not.
You're not a huge proponent
of the SORTA candice Kanye training in
general,
but the fact that that conversation is
happening now,
the fact that you made that video,
you view that all as positive,
right?
Oh yeah,
no,
for sure.
I think Connie really allowed a lot of
people to think for a second and try to
investigate some more information.
Try to figure out what their real.
Why do they hold certain ideas.
I think that was the biggest thing and
it was really exciting.
It's like scroll through facebook and
see people that are not normally
engaging in politics now.
Actually,
that might be scary because it's like
the majority of people are saying don't
know what they're doing,
but yeah,
I'd rather have them involved in some
way.
Exactly.
I would rather have them involved.
And the thing is,
I think as much as I,
um,
you know,
dislike is politics.
I do think that it opened a lot of
people's minds in the sense that it
allowed them to investigate more and
that's the most important thing because
then you're just stuck in the echo
chamber.
Connie broke that.
A lot of people,
all they see is,
you know,
beyonce and Chrissy Tiegen and all these
celebrities that are all just talking
about the far left,
you know,
super.
I hate saying social justice for ever
super social justice warrior talking
points.
So kanye broke that and showed them the
other side.
Um,
unfortunately I think,
uh,
you know,
because candace is kind of harsh and you
know,
I think it's harder for people to
connect with her that are already sold
down the drain of the far left.
And unfortunately we might have to
cuddle them,
fill it,
we'll come on,
come to the other side.
It's okay,
let me explain things to you.
So do you view that as just like a
personality trait because that's what's
interesting to me.
Like people used to say to me all the
time,
well,
you know,
if when you have milo on like Milo's
creating chaos and out of chaos,
hopefully my feeling was if I brought my
low on that out of the chaos that he
creates,
that some people would hear some good
ideas in a more calm,
relaxed way and then they joined me on
the adventure that I'm on it.
I think there's proof in that pudding.
I think you're kind of a little bit more
like where I think you see the little
bit of the chaos that candice is
creating and you want people to
understand the ideas behind them.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the thing is that,
you know,
when candice says one thing like,
um,
stop the victim mentality for example,
I think a black Americans that are stuck
in like the far left echo chamber just
sees it as like,
excuse me,
like what are you trying to save a
little blah?
So it's like they need either she
explains it further,
which obviously she doesn't have to do
with me,
she can do whatever she wants,
but I think she needs to break it down a
little more because saying get off the
plantation,
the victim hood,
it's harder for people that all they've
ever heard is white privilege,
white people suck,
blah blah blah.
It's harder for them to kind of
understand where she's coming from
because if you do break it down it makes
a lot of sense.
But if it's just rolling like that,
then it's harder for them to figure it
out.
What they can do.
The I keep pointing here like the
liberals are these people over here?
Yeah.
So it just seemed to kind of break it
down and figure
you think maybe you need both.
Like in any movement,
like if you just look at the black
rights movement that Malcolm x was
different than Martin Luther King.
And even the way comedians talk about
things differently cause we talked about
things differently than Dick Gregory
than Chappelle and Chris Rock.
We just need people.
People just get affected by it.
Different.
Yeah.
Shock value works,
I mean it gets people,
it wakes people up,
it allows them to kind of be more aware
of what's going on.
I totally,
I do think we need both of them.
We need people to say,
know,
shut up,
you're being annoying.
And we also need people to say here's
why you're being annoying.
I think we most certainly need both,
but yeah,
I think she,
what she does is she's awesome.
She has such a great platform and there
are also other people that are doing the
same thing but in a more kind of calmer.
I'm not saying she's like crazy or
anything like that.
Um,
yeah,
she's just,
she's a tough girl and it's a lot of
sjws aren't snowflakes.
So I really had any interaction.
I'm not necessarily,
I mean I think we've done under,
like we've talked over dms on twitter
before.
Um,
and this was after the whole Blair white
debate and that was white guys guys,
guys.
Yeah.
Uh,
no.
I was just at reaching out to her and
asking her like,
Hey,
what's going on?
Like I don't because she was,
I think closing everyone off that were
criticizing her and I didn't want to
openly criticize her.
I wanted to go directly to the source,
but we left off on a good note.
So yeah.
All right,
well I'll put it out here.
Why don't we have a Jay z Kanye moment
and you both can come on the show
sometime and talk it out and going to be
like guys,
guys,
guys.
I'm a glutton for punishment.
So when I was doing a little research
and I knew one of the things that I
thought was most interesting is that.
So you have a twin sister.
Yeah.
And part of your awakening was related
to a paper that she was writing in
college.
Right.
So can you tell me about that?
Because it's pretty fascinating.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
Um,
so my sister is not into politics at
all.
She is studying marketing and she
decided to take,
he was to Ryerson University,
one of the biggest far left universities
in Canada.
And um,
he took a sociology course that was her
fault and it was called how society
works.
I think it was the title of the course
or is what bothered me because if the
chorus was feminism studies,
if the course was,
you know,
how women are oppressed and yeah,
sure,
but this is how society works and you
know,
in your assignment they had to talk
about some societal issue and discuss it
and analyze it or whatever and she
wanted to talk about the weight or I
actually encouraged her.
I like you to talk about the wage gap
and you know,
how it's falls and you know,
how it's misinterpreted and all of that.
And you were sending her up.
I was setting her up a little.
I wanted to test it out,
but I didn't know it was there.
A professor would respond that way.
Um,
but yeah,
I told her to write about the wage gap.
So she just sounds like a short thesis
and said like,
here's what I want to talk about.
I'm going to use studies,
blah,
blah.
Let me know.
And the professor,
like,
her response is a meme.
Like,
I hope I could.
You guys can like put it up or
something.
It's like the reality is patriarchy do
not use business sources.
They blame women and it's like period.
The reality is patriarchy can do not
blame women and like,
you know
the screenshot on this,
you can say yes for sure.
Definitely.
Yeah,
I was reading it.
I was like,
okay,
this is fake,
right?
This is.
And this is definitely fake.
No,
she basically shut it down.
She said your premise is completely.
And it was one of the most absurd emails
ever and use only feminist sources.
And in the assignment details,
the list of sources they can't use was
dictionary.com.
The encyclopedia.
You couldn't use the government of
Canada website,
you couldn't use statistic Canada,
Statistics Canada.
How,
like how does that even make sense?
How are you going to explain how society
works?
And the only source you have is feminist
studies,
as Peterson has mentioned,
there's so many times they're not cited.
It's just within this little group,
the,
these aren't real textbooks.
Uh,
but yeah,
it just,
it blew my mind and I was so excited and
she sat back because I was like,
this is exactly what is wrong.
So.
Okay,
so your sister gets this response.
What was her response?
Was she like,
Oh,
look what you did to me?
No,
yes,
she was upset at me and she thought I
was wrong and I have to sit her down and
say,
girl,
let me explain it to you.
Here is what is actually happening.
By the end of that conversation,
she's like,
oh my gosh,
I've been.
Every class I go to,
I've been lied to.
They are lying to me every single day,
and it,
it,
it's,
it's so messed up and I think it's,
this isn't teaching.
This is imposing your political ideas on
students because if it's teaching,
you teach it objectively,
you show them the facts and let your
students come up with their own
conclusions.
This is not teaching.
She's trying to tell them how to think
and you know,
I,
I did some research on her actually and
she's the highest paid woman in her
person,
in her department.
She makes more money than the male
counterparts are you talking about?
So I'm sure there's a reason.
Yeah,
exactly.
But it's like there's obviously reasons
for it.
She probably works more hours,
she's,
you know,
doing all these other things and that's
how you can explain the wage gap.
So it was just interesting to me that
why like why are you doing this?
Why are you lying to your students or
isn't the point of education for you?
Like,
or essays or assignments like you're
supposed to come to your own conclusions
by using facts.
We have the facts.
What's wrong with it?
She just didn't want those facts.
It,
it blew my mind.
But that was the right.
Well,
they're often not for facts.
Yeah.
Facts that they allege facts.
So what,
what happened with the paper?
She's like,
okay,
this is too much for me.
My sister and she ended up just doing
some other topic and try to pander to
what the professor wanted to get a good
mark.
And that is my advice to a lot of
students is like,
just suck it up.
I mean if you are already in this class,
it's not worth getting a bad mark over.
Um,
however.
Sorry.
The great thing about it was I got a ton
of messages from students from her class
started to explain all the other things
that this teacher is engaging and how
awful it is and not made me happy
because they said,
you know what,
next week I'm going to speak up and I'm
going to tell her she's wrong.
And I was like,
yes,
but be prepared.
Don't just take you through.
So it's interesting.
So I talk about this when I do college
speeches.
Yeah.
Two years ago or so,
I used to say what you said about get
the grade,
like suck it up and get the green
because hopefully you know,
if you want to move to Grad school or
get a good job after or whatever.
And I've turned on that really to on
that because to me it's like we live in
a time where people can be on youtube
and expose these things.
Share the emails out on social media,
periscope while you're in classes.
The teacher is telling you that you're
an evil white racism videos with my
teachers.
Just the worst thing.
But that's been so empowering for you.
So that's why I'm not for telling kids
students not to do that,
but I understand the line of thinking.
Yeah.
And I guess it depends on the person or
is it's still kind of challenge your
professor while he is,
you know,
just teaching.
I meant more for assignments.
Like if the assignment says explain why
women are oppressed,
like just do it,
that that's it.
Like if you,
you're probably going to fail if you say
women are not oppressed.
Um,
but if the teacher is actually teaching
then yes please.
That is the best time because you catch
them at it.
And I love watching them squirm.
I love watching them just kind of look
around and it's like,
oh,
there's a black woman asking me to tell
you know,
tell her why she's depressed and my
white professor please tell me what
rights you have did I don't have in
Toronto,
Canada.
And it's like,
well,
you know,
there is white privilege.
And it's like,
oh my gosh,
stop.
Do you feel bizarrely empowered because
of that?
Now,
I mean someone who's clear on their
political thoughts and you don't,
you're not a victim victim or anything
or he's immigrant status or blah,
blah,
blah.
Do you feel very empowered,
like almost like your teachers can't
push back on you in a weird way because
they're,
they're caught in their own guilt cycle.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
And it's also funny because,
um,
you know,
I am the,
I am an immigrant,
I'm black and I'm a woman.
It's like I just have to be,
I guess most loving and I'm all the
impressions.
Um,
so it's really difficult for them or
anything.
Yeah.
I got to limit Stereo Mueller every
oppression there is.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
it,
it's,
it's kind of funny to see how they can't
challenge me because a lot of their
arguments,
it is based on lived experiences.
This is what black people face and I'm
talking about the Canadian context.
I think Canadian social racial relations
is a little bit different than the
states than here in the states.
Sorry.
Um,
but yeah,
me being a black woman,
it's,
it's very difficult for them that they
can't give me any,
they have to give me a legit argument
because the only argument is,
well,
black people feel that way.
I don't.
So what is your argument?
But yeah,
I mean in,
in a sense it does kind of make me feel
empowered because it's,
it's funny to watch them squirm.
Do you feel that you've had an undue
influence in,
I suspect in a positive way on some of
your classmates because I'm imagining
they're probably learning as much from
you in some ways more than they're
learning from some of these professors.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
it's actually funded.
There are some classes I would have
where a professor will say something
absurd and like there's a student that I
know knows me from Youtube and he will
look at me and I'm like,
I'm not saying anything and then they'll
raise their hand and they'll talk and
they'll want me to chime in and I'm
like,
I don't want to do this in every class.
I'm not going to be challenging my
professors.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I really liked the fact that I've
encouraged so many students step up and
actually speak up and say what they
believe in and um,
yeah,
it's just really,
it's really interesting.
There was a course where one of the
textbooks,
I forgot,
damn it,
this is why school sucks because like
you forget everything literally,
instantly.
Um,
but one of the students said how it was
problematic and before we just kind of
brush it off and then another student
rose their hand and said,
why is it problematic?
And it looks at me.
I was like,
Oh God.
But yeah,
I really liked that.
I've encouraged people to speak up and
you know,
state what they believe and do more
research and not just listen to
everything your professors saying,
not just listen to anything I'm saying
do more research and investigate and try
to find,
you know,
let's get closer to the truth is
basically it.
Do you think students want to be smarter
than this stuff?
They're being spoon fed because I
definitely do.
And when I go to these schools,
I see such a thirst for knowledge and
honesty and facts and an exhaustion with
this nonsense.
But if you listen to the way the media
talks either about millennials or
whatever,
it's like they're the spoiled entitled
generation.
And I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that a lot of them
aren't,
but I genuinely think that,
that most people,
especially young people,
they want real answers,
not just like easy dribble.
No,
for sure.
And,
um,
I think a lot of this has to do with the
student unions.
And again,
I'm talking,
I'm obviously more familiar with the
Canadian context of this,
um,
but the,
you know,
major schools,
University of Toronto,
York University in Ryerson University.
I go to University of Toronto,
run by black lives matter,
Ryerson,
black lives matter and feminist,
uh,
a university black lives matter.
I mean,
individuals that are part of the black
lives matter.
Original organizations are the
presidents,
vice president and all that of the
student union.
And,
um,
I was,
uh,
president of the debate club for about
three years,
the first three years of my schooling.
And I was like,
you know,
what would be really exciting to have a
debate on racial,
racial issues.
I would love to.
I don't care if I'm on this side,
on the other side,
that would be such a good thing because
all we're ever being bad is faced every
corner.
There's some poster about being black
and uft,
which by the way,
people just realized during the trump
election,
we've been here for three years.
No one complained and all of a sudden
trump is elected.
It's hard to be black.
Come on.
Um,
but yeah,
I,
I went to go talk to the school
president and I said I would love to
have this event.
All of that.
They shut me down.
They said anyone that goes in the other
side,
on the opposite side is,
you know,
trying to question the humanity of black
people,
how dare they try.
And I was sitting there like,
I will be the one,
like,
what are you talking about?
But yeah,
they,
they canceled it and shut it down.
It's just so sad.
It was so excited for that.
So it's interesting.
I know you've been pretty critical of
black lives matter and I want to get
into that a little bit,
but the moment for me that I realized it
had morphed into something that I no
longer felt was positive because at the
beginning I did think it was basically a
positive movement or a grassroots
movement that was making some sense and,
and addressing some important issues.
But the moment I realized that it
jumped,
the shark was in Toronto actually at the
Toronto Pride Parade.
When they stopped the parade,
they literally stopped the parade from
marching to demand that the organizers
of the Gay Pride Parade,
another oppressed group,
uh,
submit to their demands.
Whatever their demands were,
that they were gonna focus on these
issues.
And I thought,
wow,
what a perfect example of everything
that's wrong with identity politics,
with the oppression,
Olympics,
the whole thing.
And then subsequently I saw a lot more
of that style of thinking happening
throughout black lives matter.
But was that moment for you as someone
that's from Toronto?
We met in Toronto,
is that,
was that a seminal moment for you?
For sure.
I mean,
I absolutely hate black lives matter
Toronto,
I can't say much for many of the other
black lives matter chapters,
but black lives matter.
Toronto is extremely toxic and divisive
and I think it's mainly because we were
getting so much better in terms of
racial relations and people were getting
along and there wasn't really.
I mean I'm speaking for myself.
There wasn't really that many racism or
racist acts happening,
but all of a sudden they erupt and they
say,
you know,
black people feel uncomfortable during
pride because of the police.
When again happens during the trump
presidency,
it's like all of a sudden you're
starting to feel oppressed and it blew
my mind.
Stopping the pride parade.
I was so confused.
They stopped it for like an hour asking
for demands that the police be banned
and it's like being a gay police officer
isn't that?
And oppression.
And then they say,
okay,
but you can go without your uniform.
Are you kidding me?
No,
that's not the point.
The point is there was a stigma against
being,
you know,
a police officer and gay being gay.
How dare you take that away from them.
And there were a lot of proposals,
by the way,
during the pride parade with officers
and their uniform.
That's beautiful.
Like,
what are you really going to try to.
Marriage proposals.
Yeah.
And I was like,
oh my God,
this is such a great thing.
But no,
no,
no.
Now they,
they've actually been banned.
They didn't,
they're not coming to the pride,
right?
Think for the next like five years or
so.
Um,
but that actually was not the reason why
I started to hate blm.
Do you remember the Jordan Peterson free
speech event in Toronto?
Uh,
so he teaches at University of Toronto.
My school,
and this is actually when I started
making videos.
It was because during the,
the event he,
this was his first public event after
making the series of videos and um,
black lives matter was there,
you know,
just there are two sides I guess.
And I wasn't really picking aside,
it was also my very first protest.
I was just there to observe.
I was very confused as to why people are
yelling at each other.
But what's going on?
Oh,
I should have just got home.
Uh,
yeah.
So I,
I,
you know,
I observed the whole thing and it was
pretty peaceful.
There are people of color went up there
and we're saying things like,
you know,
I don't feel oppressed.
This is one of the greatest countries in
the world.
Especially Toronto.
Like this is so diverse.
It's everyone loves each.
Everyone's nice to each other.
Um,
you know,
the black lives matter,
recalling them coons,
they're calling them sellouts,
they're yelling all these things.
And I immediately knew who the
aggressors were.
I immediately knew who,
which side I did not want to be on.
I wasn't picking sides,
but I was like,
Oh God,
I stayed till the very end til the last
person left because this was again first
protest.
I was like excited and talking to
everyone.
I got home and there are articles that
are posted by the school newspaper by
Toronto,
Star about black people were,
you know,
called the n word.
They were harassed.
Someone brought dogs.
Someone brought up.
I was actually standing next to the
person with the dogs.
So when apparently brought dogs to chase
off the black,
black people complete lies,
and that opened my eyes to like the
media bias that didn't happen,
not even close to being happening to
happen.
So it blew my mind that they would lie
about that.
And then I personally messaged,
uh,
the leader of black lives matter
instead,
I'm disappointed girl.
I was.
They're like,
what?
Why are you doing this?
And then I decided to start making
videos because I said clearly they're
getting the wrong information.
The school literally things.
Jordan Peterson was this Nazi that came
and said I hate black people and women
and transgenders and all of that.
So I just thought no one's going to do
it.
I should do it.
And then I started making videos,
which was weird because I had to go to
school the next day and then deal with
it.
These people know what you,
you put your ass on the line and it's
paid off.
Wait.
So did.
When you dim the black lives matter
president,
did she respond to you?
Yeah,
she was wanting to me saying,
I'm,
I'm going to screenshot this,
uh,
to use against you in the future.
Why don't you say it to my face?
I still have it saved because I'm like,
I,
I'm gonna save this for the rest of my
life.
Yeah.
The,
the president,
like the cofounder of black lives matter
Toronto said she's gonna I should stay,
stay to her face and she's going to use
this against me.
The future.
Meanwhile,
all I said was I was there.
This was very inappropriate.
Why are you telling lies or making black
people feel like,
you know,
this is what actually happened.
You're making students feel like that's
why students feel like they're being
oppressed because you're telling them.
Sorry,
what?
No,
what do you think these people,
and I don't mean just black lives matter
in this case,
but like this,
this type of person at a university,
whether it's from gender studies or
whatever it is,
you know,
with all the identity politics stuff,
what do you think they actually want in
the end?
Like if they were to get what they want,
what is that?
That's what I don't understand is that
they are obviously fakes because if they
truly care about black liberation,
there are policies that you could point
to that you can probably fix and help
the black community.
And in Canada one of the things was a
carding and that was actually
immediately carding was gone.
I'm in Toronto,
Ontario.
I'm not sure either the province or the
city.
Um,
but that's the one thing where I was
like,
okay,
random stops.
I think that's something that you should
be stopped and it's done in inner city
neighborhoods and blah,
blah,
blah.
Apart from that,
it's like,
okay,
what else do you want?
They want black professors.
They want to police out of pride that's
not helping black people.
That's not changing their social
economic status.
So what do you,
what is your goal?
I really don't understand because it's.
You don't care.
I don't want to say I do care.
I want to say like I'm,
I have all the solutions,
but I can tell you what to do.
But they're telling people false
solutions.
They're telling them that we need all
black professors to teach black people.
But I don't know what their,
what their goal is.
I don't know if it's money.
I guess I don't get it or you don't get
it seriously.
Alright.
So let's shift to Jordan Peterson a
little bit because you are a student at
the University of Toronto.
That's where he's been teaching for many
years.
This whole kerfuffle over transgender
person.
All his fault that the school is so like
everyone's yelling at each other and
hate each other.
I blame him.
What's the atmosphere like at the
school?
Actually he's not teaching there right
now.
We could obviously he's on tour and the
book and the whole thing,
but how has the atmosphere change then,
do you think it's directly related to
some of the stuff that he on earth?
I think it has changed because there you
can see the groups and when someone has
a slightly right wing or.
It's funny because the fact that they
associate individualism and the fact
that they associate thinking for
yourself with being right wing,
it's like,
why would you want to do that?
It should not be anyways.
Why wouldn't you want to be right wing?
Right,
exactly.
Exactly,
like what?
Yeah.
Uh,
so the,
when you're a little bit more right
wing,
I guess they tend to say that,
you know,
you are a Jordan Peterson fan and you
hate transgenders and blah blah blah,
like there's a clear divide you can tell
which side people are on.
Um,
but I,
yeah,
I think it was bound to happen
regardless and just again because of the
trump presidency to like,
can we just blame trump for everything?
Yes.
You're in America now in California too.
So that's how I view it as kind of a
necessary evil that he sort of got this
stuff.
I mean,
again,
it goes to what we were talking about
earlier,
like some of these people get these
issues out there and then hopefully some
goodness.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
And um,
I think the other thing is trump allowed
people,
like I said earlier,
to think for themselves in the sense to
understand that maybe not everything is
how it seems.
Maybe things that I'm learning is not
exactly how it is and you know,
I,
you know,
I may disagree with his politics because
I'm a liberal in general.
Um,
but I do think that yeah,
it was bound to happen and trump kind of
shook things up and allow a lot more
people are engaging in politics now,
which is so exciting and also really
scary at the same time.
Or is it that it,
I mean that's it right there.
I think just this morning I tweeted
something out to that effect.
It's like,
wow,
it's incredibly exciting.
It doesn't mean things are going to be
good.
I actually,
uh,
I believe things actually are going to
get better because there's so many cool
new young people like yourself out there
putting out ideas like I have hope,
but yet doesn't mean that that's how
it's gonna go.
It might go the other way.
But then the other thing is that because
I'm the far left are scared that people
are starting to do more research you to
Google things.
Nowadays they've started to,
that's why they want to control google.
Exactly.
So now you can't find any information.
You can only find there's.
Yeah.
But now they're changing definitions of
things.
So I mean the definition of racism is no
longer individual.
It has to do with power plus privilege.
So in other words,
only white people can be racist towards
minorities.
Minorities cannot be racist towards
white people.
Um,
they've also taken hold of the student
unions and Jordan Peterson has talked
about this a lot.
I'm so sorry,
what was the question that generally was
about Jordan and being a student at
University of Toronto that.
So just keep going.
Yeah.
I just feel like I'm,
the student unions are just influencing
a lot of the students and they're
influencing a lot of the events that are
happening.
They,
they claim to speak on behalf of all
students.
So,
and they claim that they're fighting
against racism except they define it a
different way.
I was going to go against someone that
says we're fighting against racism and
sexism and every other buzzword that
they can throw out there,
you have to accept it.
Um,
and because they've changed the
definition of racism,
they've started to have events and there
was a white privileged conference,
which I actually did a video on at
Ryerson University.
Yeah.
So that's the way that they're
countering it.
They're countering the facts with just,
you know,
all that alternative facts with their
own,
a BS,
feminist studies ideas,
I don't even know,
but that's,
I guess the way they're doing it.
They're trying to influence students
from schools,
so then when they get out they can
become more liberal.
So the things that Jordan talks about
when he talks about the individual and
when he talks about why the government
shouldn't be able to talk,
tell you what pronouns do you use,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You see these things as all directly
related to everything else that you've
been talking about here.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
And I think it's also about,
um,
sorry I just blanked.
We were at a Jordan event,
that's where we met about a month ago in
Toronto.
And was it a white supremacists
man?
I was stoned on my way out.
I mean,
but were you surprised at all when you
saw what type of girl and an interesting
diverse young.
I think most of them I've been telling
people it's about 60 slash 40 male to
female,
but sometimes it's even closer to 50
slash 50.
Yeah,
no,
I think it's pretty diverse and I've
gone to several events,
political events,
I guess where I look in the crowd,
I'm like,
wow,
there's a lot of minorities here.
There's women here,
there's men here,
there's everyone here,
and sorry,
where I where I blanked was the idea
that you can't.
You can't debate something.
That's where that was the whole pd.
I'm like ranting here so I can get you
all excited because I was there so he
has this effect on people,
but the fact that you can't debate
certain topic,
the fact that you can debate whether or
not we should use certain pronouns
because they say,
well,
you're questioning my identity.
You're questioning me as a person.
My humanity.
They turn it around and make it sound
like you hate that person.
And that's the thing is it's not like I
agree with Peterson or I agree with the,
you know,
the students.
I just want to hear both sides.
That's all I'm asking for.
Something.
We can all make an informed conclusion,
but they don't want you to hear both
sides.
They want you to hear their side and
that is the only site you see what
happened with Lindsay Shepherd as well,
where she played a peterson debates
where they're all sides and they don't
want you to hear that.
They only want you to hear their side.
And that's where,
that's one thing I hate the most is just
the lack of discussion.
Yeah.
So I'm glad you brought up Lindsey
because that also is happening in
Canada.
That was at Wilfrid laurier university.
Now there's a lawsuit that she's
involved in and I suspect I read some of
the initial brief.
I mean,
I think this thing is going to be a
bloodbath diversity,
um,
but what does that say is happening in
Canada in a larger way?
I think you've kind of hit on this a
little bit,
like you guys are almost having like
this,
like trump hangover or something where,
or even the black lives matter thing,
like it didn't start in America as you
said,
race relations were different in Canada.
I would argue they're still great here.
It doesn't for sure.
Kevin Canadians are just nicer.
Okay.
Just generally you guys,
you know,
we've done two shows in Toronto and the
shows were totally nice and pleasant,
but like we've gone to some other cities
where,
and I find it's usually in the
progressive cities,
so it's been in San Francisco and it's
been in Seattle and a couple of the
others where the crowds are the craziest
most rockets,
which is what I like those because they
kind of,
they need his message.
Toronto,
you guys were very pleasant,
very pleasant.
Think we're getting to a point where we
need his message.
I think it's getting a little scary,
especially with a trudeau our prime
minister,
he's kind of going to a lot of the
social justice warrior and um,
the fact that he's even,
you know,
talking to black lives matter Toronto,
who know the leader,
one of the leaders said she wants to
kill a white man.
She tweeted that she wished she could
kill all white men and the other one
actually stole $300,000
from my student union,
stole it and said that she on her last
day,
she filed her overtime and she's filed
thousands of hours of overtime and said
$300,000
worth of one of our entire budget of our
student unions by a third and here's the
best part of it.
She files that.
Obviously there's alerts that go off.
You can't take that much money for what
are your student union president?
$300,000.
Sure.
There aren't that many hours in the day,
but here's the thing.
She claimed that the majority of those
hours come from work that she does for
the black community for like black lives
matter.
That doesn't count.
No one is asking you that's not
affiliated with the school.
No one's asking you.
Whatever you do at home has nothing to
do with that.
I always.
The school obviously said they wanted
the money back.
They try to sue her and they started a
whole campaign saying,
my university is anti black,
and then they started to put posters up.
They got gathered,
a bunch of people saying that you're
their only suing her because she's
black.
You stole $300,000.
You took $300,000.
Girl like,
are you because you're a black,
are you kidding me?
Does that not even.
Anyway,
she,
you know,
they vandalized the student union.
They have megaphones starts yelling,
saying anti black racism happened to
your hands.
And it was just this whole ordeal.
Like it's,
Ugh,
Gosh.
Anyways,
what have you found the best arguments
to get people your age to wake up to
some of this stuff?
Like,
I know obviously they're watching your
videos,
probably your,
your prime way of doing it,
but if you found simple arguments,
simple phrases or whatever that you can
use to get some people out of this.
Everything can be explained away through
a social economic standpoint.
A lot of the issues that the black
community faces because they're poor,
which is the same issues that poor white
community space as well.
And,
um,
I,
you know,
there examples of black Americans and
Black Canadians that do,
do well to do well and uh,
you have to look at why they're doing
well.
Okay.
So they have higher education,
you know,
there's,
they're both parents at home.
There were all these different factors
to look at it and then it's like,
oh,
so it's not just the color,
my skin,
it's either choices or I make or the
area I'm in,
the surroundings I'm in or the school I
went to rather than just,
it's the color of my skin.
Um,
but I think you just have to break it
down to that before a lot of people can
understand where I'm coming from and why
they think a certain way.
Um,
it's just,
it's easy to just to say,
well,
it's because I'm black and I'm not doing
as well.
It's,
no,
there's,
there's so many different ways to
explain it.
How do you rub up all the stuff that
they might say about you?
Because I have enough friends that are
black conservatives or,
or are kind of liberal,
whatever you want to call it,
that the things that I see good that
gets said about them all time.
Every time Larry elder comes and does my
show and I look on twitter,
the things that.
The things that's the suppose ID
tolerant people,
right?
The progressives,
the lefties that they say about this man
who I know is being authentic.
Well,
it's ridiculous.
I mean I get a lot of hate comments
where it's,
you know,
they'll call me coon.
They say hate myself.
I want to be white.
All these different things.
It's the one part is like me speaking
this way or speaking,
I guess I don't want to say proper
English per se,
but I'm trying to be white.
I'm trying to be something I'm not and
it's like,
why are you fitting people a race in a
group?
You're just allowing white people just
to say,
well,
black people are just dumb because it
means saying we all act the same way and
we should all think the same way.
That means you can.
Every black person can be explained with
one statement.
That's not fair.
It let us all be individuals.
In fact,
you should be fighting for us to be
individuals and have our own ideas.
Why are we trying to form groups?
And then they wonder why,
why there's all these like white
supremacist groups forming up because
you've already.
It's a sites thing.
You said there's our side and there's
your side through like,
okay,
sure,
we'll form a group I guess and go
against you.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean I don't,
a lot of the hate comments are just
useless.
I ignore the epithets,
but I do try to understand a lot of the
criticism and again,
it's just not understanding where I'm
coming from.
It's not,
you know,
getting their stocks from the right
place,
the root.com
or onion is not somewhere to get your
facts right,
but that you compare those.
But when I,
um,
you know,
get into a detailed discussion with a
lot of them,
then they understand where I'm coming
from and it's like there's this light
that shines.
And they do that at my school a lot as
well.
At where someone that absolutely hates
me,
I spend a whole day talking to them and
at the end I call it like it's really
awful to use this conversion therapy or
to say that we're not electrocuting no,
but by the end of it it's like their
minds are blown because they just
believed everything.
Black lives matter said everything the
mainstream left media have said,
so it's.
I think it's just you just got to talk
to them.
They don't want to talk.
They're stuck in an echo chamber.
This
intersectionality in this combining of
perceived depressions,
something that will just sort of crap
out under its own weight.
So like for example,
if you're going to keep saying,
well black people should or this
minority,
whatever that minority is,
should get easier entrance to this or
access to this or whatever.
What you're actually saying is while
other people are going to have to be
punished based on their immutable
characteristics,
we see this now.
I mean,
I see a massive happening with the Asian
community right now in America because
by every metric that we judge success,
they are succeeding at extremely high
levels because of hard work and
education and commitment to family.
But if you're going to start saying,
well,
we're going to have to take less of them
because we have to take more of other
people.
You're actually setting these groups to
hate each other.
Yeah.
That is so deep.
Exactly.
And you're telling one group that they
can't do it on their own.
And um,
there is some studies,
I forgot who it was who wrote it,
but it was called the mismatch theory,
which is,
um,
a lot of the minority students are
getting thrown in.
Universities are not qualified,
actually turn out worse when they come
out.
They don't get jobs because they don't
have the actual skills that they needed
to get in.
But yeah,
it creates this kind of tension.
Why would you tell someone that,
you know,
there are more important just because of
the color of your skin.
It's going to piss other people off.
Um,
it's,
I don't think that's a way to move
forward.
I don't think that's a way to progress,
but yeah,
and the whole intersectionality thing,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
The Pride Parade,
I guess in Toronto is an example of
that.
It's like my issues are more important.
And then obviously the Lgbtq community,
they all hated that and they were all
very upset with it because it's like
pride is one of the most inclusive
events in the,
in the city.
Why are you trying to ruin it and say
this is a black thing.
It's an everybody thing.
We're,
we're all advocating for everyone here.
So it's,
it's,
they're just going to go into ruined
themselves that they keep adding.
So speaking of that,
I saw the thing that you did,
you were not happy when they put the
black and brown stripes into the rainbow
flag,
which I also thought was completely
ridiculous.
The whole point is that this is for
everybody.
We're not looking at all your
differences.
Racist.
Yeah.
But reverse segregation,
I really don't get it.
The white privilege conference advising
university,
that's reversed segregation and I
actually gave them the benefit of the
doubt.
I'm like,
I'm going to ignore the name,
I'm going to actually try to see what
they're trying to teach.
And ultimately the end,
the conclusion of this event was listen
to people,
listen to what people are saying.
So anecdotes only listened to people's
feelings.
So it's like,
that's not how you form a society.
It's the majority were white women.
They were just sitting there hearing
black people tell them,
just listen to our stories because we
know and we experience it and you know
you have to have a black spaces.
In fact,
there is someone that tweeted during the
event saying,
I'm a woman just rose her hand to speak
while white splaining wait for the for
later where we have our white corner so
we can talk about,
you know,
art,
what is this?
What kind of society are we preparing
herself for?
It's literally reversed segregation,
segregation in the true sense of the
word.
And I,
yeah,
I really don't.
What,
what do you make of the guilty white
allies?
Those people,
you know,
when I've had a,
I know you met Bret Weinstein from
evergreen and heather,
his wife,
I'm one of the things that fascinated me
most when he was going through the
ordeal there was that he said he never
feared the black students physically or
the brown students or whatever it was.
The,
it was the white allies he said that had
this sort of look in their eye,
like they,
the ones that could get violent and I've
seen that,
that look,
what do you make of that data?
He treated because it's hard to.
Because there,
if you're not black then.
I mean they're trying to explain it.
If you're not black then you don't
experience it,
then you don't understand it.
So as a white ally you have to just take
everything,
you know,
an activist says to you as fat as this
is what is happening.
I'm one of the speakers actually,
he did an interview for the Toronto Star
and they asked him and that was like,
okay,
what?
Where do you see white privilege in
Toronto?
And he said literally,
I mean I'm paraphrasing,
but he said when you walk into a store,
black people or black people have to
think about the fact that people are
watching them.
Okay,
sure.
I was like,
fine,
whatever.
But apparently black people have to pay
for items in one section before they can
move to another section so they don't
get accused of stealing.
That's his,
his.
He got a chance to tell us what white
privilege is.
And that was his example of white
privilege.
Is that happening?
And no,
I've never.
It's never happened.
I've worked retail for like the most of
my life.
What you're going to pay the kids
section before you go to the men's
section.
Like what world is this guy living in my
mind and another one did an article
where it's how the outdoors is racist
and how people feel like the,
you know,
skiing and hiking and everything is a
white space and therefore black people
don't want to go to it.
And it's like,
who you're saying it,
you were the one that are making these
claims.
Why are we there?
It's just more division.
It's more like,
it just,
it pisses me off.
Yeah.
You know what?
Because you're visiting La for a couple
of days,
I don't have a ton of time,
but maybe we could go on a quick hike
and see what happens.
Black woman,
but it just like,
you're obviously don't care about the
betterments of the black community
because he wouldn't be talking about
these non issues here in the stage.
You can talk about,
you know,
uh,
sorry,
how old the education system works.
You can talk about the war on drugs.
You can talk about the prison system,
but yet the amount of people they got to
protest the Trayvon Martin shooting.
If you can get that many people to
protest the war on drugs,
you can probably make a change.
But no,
they're going to focus on police
shootings is one of the least things
that are actually affecting black
Americans.
But yet that's what they want to put
their focus on.
So how much of the root of that is just
lazy thinking.
Like it's easy to get people genned up
about a shooting per se,
and I'm not,
I'm not diminishing that are wrong.
Obviously it's easier to take all of the
anecdotal stuff.
The woman at the shopping center who
this happened to you or that.
Yeah,
it's always easier to do that than to
really be like,
let's really look at the prison systems,
which I would be for looking.
Yeah.
I would be figuring out ways that we can
do better education to minority
communities that have been neglected.
All of those things,
but those things aren't really sexy.
They're not like the things that get
people out on the streets for more than
a day.
It's the other stuff.
So part of this is just human nature,
right?
Yeah,
I totally agree.
I mean,
I,
I can base all my arguments on
anecdotes,
but that doesn't like,
that means nothing to me.
I can say,
oh well this one day I've lived in
Toronto all my life and I've never
experienced racism.
I'm not going to use that as facts,
but yeah,
but it's so much easier to do so it's so
much easier to play with the
heartstrings and say like,
this is what's really happening,
but it's just,
it's just sad that there are actual
policies that can be changed or put in
place that could actually uplift the
black community,
but you know,
none of the people that are claimed to
be the activist care and especially the
celebrities,
which really annoys me beyond seeing Jay
z,
all they do is talk about,
you know,
black rights and blah blah.
Why don't you use your billion dollars
to,
you know,
create some rehabilitation center for
people that are getting out of prison.
Why don't you try to fight for the war
on drugs?
Like it's all these things where it's,
it's.
Yeah,
it's,
it's easy just to say,
oh look,
there's a shooting,
you know,
this is what black people experience
every day and you know,
white people are racist.
The end.
No,
it's,
there's,
I don't know,
it's easier for them to just to say,
look at this anecdote and this shooting
and that's what's affecting us.
But there's so many other things that
could be done.
A little bit of my appearance,
a university,
New Hampshire when those kids were.
Oh yeah,
that one woman who,
I don't think it was a student,
I think she was either a mother of a
student or,
or 10 advisors.
And when she kept saying,
you know,
these kids pointing to the black kids
could get shot when they walk out of
here.
She's talking about a university of New
Hampshire.
And it's like,
I actually,
that was one of the only moments where I
didn't know what to say because it's so
crazy to say that like,
you're not going to be shot and you walk
out of here.
And I think I maybe said something to
that effect.
But like,
it's like that's really dangerous,
that line of thinking.
I totally agree.
And I was actually having a headline to
a comedy club the other day and there's
this guy on stage.
He was like typical inner city black
youth or whatever.
And uh,
he,
after he had stopped,
he came to sit at my table.
Everyone was gone and he made a comment
saying,
wow,
it was really hard to be a black woman
in this country and this is again,
this is Canada.
I feel like there's no excuses for
Canada.
Like,
get Outta here.
And they asked him,
okay,
how?
And he's just like,
I don't know,
it's just,
it's really hard to be a woman in black.
I'm like,
yeah,
I get the whole woman thing because you
know,
men are physically bigger and blah blah
blah.
Um,
but why is it hard for me to be black
in,
in Toronto specifically?
And he was like,
you know,
cause,
it's just white privilege.
I'm like,
no,
no.
Give me two reasons.
Give me concrete reasons could not come
up with one because there isn't.
You can't come up with when you have to
use the anecdotes,
you have to use the,
you know,
if you walk out the street,
you're going to get shot.
Why?
What are the statistics of people that
get shot by police?
Oh seven get shot by police per year.
And it's not recorded by race and it's
also doesn't tell us if they're armed or
unarmed,
seven people and you're telling me
you're more likely to walk out the door
as a black person get shot.
That's not an epidemic.
It's an epidemic.
The crime in black communities,
that's an epidemic.
But you want to ignore that and just
talk about the other.
Yeah.
Anecdote that pull at the heartstrings
and make people feel guilty and oh,
it's a waste of time.
It's such a waste of time.
But what do your parents think about
what you're doing?
Well,
they are conservative so they love it.
So what makes you not conservative with.
So if someone was to say you're,
you're conservative.
I watch your videos,
talk about conservatism
is not that bad,
blah,
blah blah.
Why would you not say you're sort of
putting aside the exhaustion of labels.
Okay.
Well I will say I'm fiscally
conservative.
So I guess I do believe in like lower
taxes in some sense.
I do believe in the free market.
I do believe in,
you know,
less regulations,
all that fun stuff.
But at the same time,
I do think that there should be some
sort of social safety net and uh,
you know,
living in Canada where there is no,
I'm sorry,
free health,
not free healthcare,
universal healthcare and you know,
at the universal education,
the education system is amazing.
The funding for the education system is
amazing.
It.
So stuff like that where I think I'm a
little bit more liberal where I do think
the government should help in some way,
but it's because I'm used to it.
It's what I grew up with and I haven't
really seen anything different and it
works,
works fine.
So I guess that.
And I'm pro choice.
Um,
so stuff like that where I really do
stand firm in my liberal views and ideas
and then,
yeah,
I'm fiscally conservative.
Yeah.
Well we're pretty much aligned.
Finally found somebody.
Now we can go out hiking or we can start
beating people.
Exactly.
I don't know what we're supposed to be.
Once you find an ally,
then you start attacking other people.
I think that's how it works.
Something like that.
Where do you want to go with all this?
I've seen,
I've seen your channel grow,
I think obviously,
you know,
having you here,
it'll,
it'll help boost your profile a little
bit.
You can go into politics.
What are you going to do?
Prime Minister of Canada,
take out that Trudeau guy with his fancy
socks.
What do you mean?
Oh Gosh.
Um,
or maybe maybe Peterson will do it,
but you could probably be in his
cabinet.
Yeah,
definitely.
Sorry.
Well,
I'm enjoying what I'm doing now and I'm
quite surprised that people even enjoy
watching my videos.
It's like it's cool to do something you
love and people like it as well.
Like I really am having fun doing it and
I think I would probably go into
politics later in life.
I mean I am doing political science.
It has to be useful somewhere.
I've been toying around with law,
but again,
I'm not sure if I really want to be in,
you know,
the whole.
I don't know if I want to deal with law
school,
but,
and I am starting actually a podcast
with my boyfriend,
which I will be uploading very soon.
Nice.
Yeah.
Uh,
the way we should tell people,
still find out otherwise your boyfriend
is white,
right into it means you could have
potentially children who look black.
They might look white.
Look,
a little bit of both.
You've talked about that a little bit.
It doesn't really matter to you.
No,
of course not.
No.
Uh,
yeah.
My boyfriend being white has been used
as like an attack against me saying
like,
wow,
look at you.
What did they say?
Sleeping with the devil or something
like that.
And it's just,
it seems like a decent fella.
He's a great guy playing Nintendo.
No,
he's a great guy.
But again,
it's,
it's the whole idea of why are you
creating more a divisiveness and then
saying you want equality.
Why are you saying a black woman being
with a white man is bad?
And then say,
wow,
white people are mean to me.
Like you either want equality or you
don't.
You either want individuality or you
don't pick one.
You can't have both.
You can't.
I'm sorry.
But yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm not 100 percent sure where exactly I
will be in the next five years.
I'm having fun with what I'm doing now.
I work for the National Post,
which I absolutely love.
Um,
and then I have the podcast coming,
so that's what I'm going to do for now.
And maybe I might get into politics,
but.
Oh,
it's so messy.
The fact that you even are go in that
far right now.
You're doing it.
Oh God.
I hate to tell you.
I can see it now.
Exciting.
I'll have somebody to support and care.
You know what you get.
You do something in Canada where you run
and you become something.
Mayors,
something you want to do.
I will consider moving all my tickets.
I will give you,
if you can pull it off,
it will be a big freaking test.
See what happens.
Definitely.
You think I do.
Okay.
There are white guy.
Oh No,
I'm sorry.
You're done.
You're done for it.
You're going to have to start giving me
like half of your page is because you
know,
racism and stuff.
Yeah.
But I think one thing that I would
actually probably liked to do,
which I probably will not be able to,
but uh,
to do a lot of work in inner city
communities because I,
I,
I don't want to say I've lived through
it,
but I understand what's going on there.
I understand that,
you know,
there's a high crime understand that in
some neighborhoods the schools aren't as
good for Canada,
it's a little different.
But I'd like to do some work there where
I can kind of tell them,
hey,
I got out and here's what I did to get
out.
And you can do it too.
There's so many.
There's opportunities there for you.
Like if you were poor minority child
right now,
please just try your hardest at school,
get an education.
It's literally one of the greatest
opportunities that you can have.
And you're more likely.
I mean,
you're probably not a hundred percent
grade,
but you're more likely to be successful
if you get an education.
And that's the one thing a lot of black
people are lacking is the education
components.
And um,
you know,
we don't really have like the war on
drugs and everything,
so it really is weird for me that in the
inner cities of Toronto where there's
still this very high crime,
there's still this tension.
Um,
but,
you know,
have you ever heard of the Woodson
Center by any chance?
It's a nonprofit organization that's
located in DC,
but I've been working with them for some
time and they basically do the same
thing.
They go out to these neighborhoods and
they help students and they have such a
good success rate.
They held them in high school because
that's the other thing is that a lot of
black kids are not even graduating high
school.
Of course they're going to go into crime
if you're not even graduating high
school.
Um,
so yeah,
they work with a lot of students there.
They have rehabilitation centers,
they help,
you know,
a black,
sorry,
black Americans reintegrate into
society.
Like it's stuff like that where it's
these root movements that I really liked
to do.
And I know it's a,
it's a big dream,
but I think that's where it would
probably be happiest is where I can show
people how it's done and help them and
hopefully everyone can copy that and
say,
Oh,
this is what we're supposed to do and
all of that.
But awesome.
I love it and I have no doubt that
you're going to do it.
And you guys can follow this future
member of Canadian parliament on her
youtube channel right here.
It's youtube.com/.
My name is Josephine.